il s'est passé un tas de choses en
disant c'est un miracle qu'on soit là
tous les deux
j'ai eu une seconde chance et je compte
bien en profiter
mais je veux que tu sois à mes côtés
on va guérir le monde
[Musique]
les gars c'est mon meilleur ami Harry
salut
tiens je m'attendais pas à tomber sur un
ours
ouais j'ai un nouveau nom pour toi
Craven
du sexy tu as besoin de moi je serai là
vous savez pas ce que vous m'avez pris
tout ce qui intéresse Maes c'est d'être
un meilleur Spiderman il ne parle que
c'est quoi ce délire avec mythe il est
pas lui-même
votre rêve
je n'ai pas l'intention de te perdre
nous allons guérir le monde
[Applaudissements]